merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues lorsqu'un
ministre se déplace les moyens de la
république c'est à dire les moyens
qu'ils appartiennent à la nation tout
entière sont mis à sa disposition
il devrait dans ces conditions se faire
un devoir de laisser de côté toute
attitude qui conduirait à privilégier
les représentants d'une chambre plus
qu'une autre
ou pire à faire en sorte que sa famille
politique soit favorisé alors que les
déplacements se multiplient les
modalités de l'organisation de ceux ci
laissent désormais ce sont jeunes ainsi
les préfets précise par écrit que
dorénavant compte tenu des conditions
sanitaires et du maintien des gestes
barrières
il avait été fait le choix qu un député
représentera l'ensemble des
parlementaires députés et sénateurs
toutes tendances politiques confondues
c'est pour le moins restrictif et le
hasard faisant bien les choses
il semblerait que très majoritairement
les circonscriptions concernées par ces
visites ministérielles soit celle
détenue par les députés de la république
en marche ou de votre majorité
madame le ministre cette situation je l'
ai personnellement vécu lors de la
visite de messieurs riester et le moine
venu à orléans pour rencontrer les
professionnels de la culture et de
tourisme est à nouveau lors d'une visite
ministérielle ce matin même à la base
aérienne de bricy évincer la
représentation nationale n'est pas
propre à mon département
mes collègues de saône-et-loire des
yvelines de haute garonne de l'oise et
d'autres départements ont ces derniers
jours vécu exactement la même situation
ils sont devenus persona non grata leur
présence républicaine n'étant pas la
bienvenue
mon collègue du doubs a même été
congédié par le préfet d'une
manifestation patriotique
la dérive est donc nationale et
l'initiative ne peut plus être celle
d'un préfet et les s'agit-il alors des
instructions gouvernementales qui
voudraient écarter les sénateurs et
surtout aucun parti ne peut être la
république à lui seul pensez vous madame
la ministre qu'il est légitime de
privilégier les députés la plupart du
temps de votre majorité jusqu'à décider
qu'à eux seuls ils représentent toutes
sensibilités et ke sol il représente à
la fois l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat
je vous remercie
merci de vos réponses
la secrétaire d'état auprès du premier
ministre porte-parole du gouvernement
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui va me permettre d'éclaircir
les choses en matière de déplacements de
membres du gouvernement
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
périodes la première période a été celle
du confinement
durant cette période les déplacements
ministériels ont été évidemment réduit
au strict nécessaire vous l'avez sans
doute vous même constaté et nous avons
eu effectivement des consignes
nationales permettant de réduire à la
fois au maximum les délégations
ministérielles mais également les
délégations qui pouvait accueillir les
ministres sur place à l'exception
parfois d'élus dont la fonction par
exemple si j'ai au conseil
d'administration d'un établissement
rendait obligatoire leur présence au
cours du déplacement
cela se comprend aisément compte tenu de
la situation particulière que nous
vivions depuis le 11 mai cette situation
particulière malgré tout perdure même si
les conditions sanitaires ont été
améliorées au fur et à mesure du temps
au fond depuis le 11 mai c'est
l'intelligence collective qui doit
dominer nous devons nous imposer en tant
que ministre les mêmes conditions que
celles qui sont imposées en matière
sanitaire à l'ensemble des français
la distanciation physique le respect des
gestes barrières il y a donc à chaque
déplacement ministériel
un regard qui est posé sur la nature du
déplacement les endroits où ce
déplacement a lieu est ce que c'est à
l'intérieur avec ce que c'est à
l'extérieur
est-ce qu'il ya matière à pouvoir avoir
un grand nombre de personnes autour du
ministre l'application stricte des
mesures barrières des gestes de
distanciation et des gestes des gestes
barrière doit être notre priorité pour
que ces déplacements ministériels puisse
se dérouler
dans de bonnes conditions je me sois
aisément monsieur le sénateur qu'il soit
parfois difficile de comprendre ces
situations qu'il puisse y avoir des
frustrations de l'incompréhension mais
je crois qu'il ne faut là y voir
absolument aucune malice politique ni
aucun prix village qu'ils soient
adressés à qui que ce soit et je
m'étonne que d'angers lancent
démocratique
d'aucuns estiment qu'il s'agit de
quitter la salle les préfets pour
clôturer mon intervention font
évidemment oeuvre de discernement ils
appliquent le décret du 13 décembre du
13 septembre 1991
plus on monte on réunit public et les
préséances pour déterminer qui doit être
présent avec un objectif évidemment de
boucle est bouclée
les gestes barrière je vous remercie la
parole est à madame martine filière pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain de
la parole merci